if you are having issues with stubborn
fat our next guest dr nash
she can help take a look at what she did
for sarah
in just three short months of losing
weight i've lost 52 pounds and 35 inches
off my waist which is where i wanted it
most
wow dr nash i love having you on the
show and i love looking at these
testimonials these results and
sarah she is one of my favorites tell me
tell us more
about sarah yeah i love looking at sarah
too because she's a prime example of
somebody who dealt with
stubborn weight loss and it finally
resolved so
sarah had underlying issues that were
going on that was driving
all this extra body fat right there in
the middle part of her body right there
in the belly
and when she would eat less and move
more like she does on a regular diet
the body just wouldn't respond or the
weight would come right back
so when we were able to get to those
underlying issues that drive that
hideous belly fat that we're looking at
she loses 50 pounds on my program she
actually went on to lose 98
and she lost 35 inches alone just in
that stubborn belly fat area
amazing results so what are the top
three issues
about weight loss that your program
solves the three underlying issues that
we go after is a dietary hormone
imbalance most people think
sex hormones like menopause but we're
talking about dietary hormones
there's 12 of them that can cause
cravings hunger stubborn belly fat the
second thing that we work on
is fatty liver disease which now is
affecting over 45
of the country and then the final one is
inflammation which is just another way
of saying
fire but that fire attacks our organs
and it drives
belly fat so all of this culminates in
this big bulbous belly button thigh
problem
that doesn't respond when we just eat
less and move more we've seen so many of
your clients and the results what can
one someone's watching right now what
can they expect when it comes to weight
loss
the amount of weight sure so
traditionally when we do a weight loss
program
we'll see something like one or two
pounds a week that's what standard
weight loss programs show but when we
target the damage at the
same time my programs typically get
three to
seven pounds on average a week and it
targets that stubborn and dangerous
belly fat
sarah is an example of that the proof is
in the pudding with her also too i love
about you dr nash is
is we see the proof with you because how
many years ago you lost one 80 pounds
over yeah i get it i love it
was it 11 years ago you've kept it off
it looked beautiful
11 years of an 80 pound weight loss
which was a weight loss program i
struggled for a weight loss problem i
struggled for over 25 years since i was
eight years old
every time you come on the show you
always bring a special what do you have
for us today
i absolutely do so normally to do that
evaluation with me it's 97
if you were to just call my office but
if you mentioned that you saw me with jc
on
the las vegas now show i have 10 spots
available where i'm going to drop it
down to less than 10. 9.97
the only way to get it is to go on to
that website
that they're flashing on the screen
because i've already got the
appointments set up there right but you
could get it for less than ten dollars
find out if you're stuck struggling with
any of these underlying problems
and if so how can we accelerate your
weight loss and get your body to change
in 2021